- Well, well, well.
Ol' Herbstreit believes players should serve their time.
- Not so fast, my friend.
- No, please! You’re going against conventional draft wisdom!
- Make like me in the preseason…
Drop 'em.
- Hop on the bandwagon! It’s crowded now.
- What’s good, bro?
- Hey, Joe.
- Oh, hello. Pleasure.
- So I said to them, if the Titans are a one seed, I’d hate to see what a seven seed is.
- [Chuckling]
- The Bengals have officially arrived!
- Can’t have a party without Uno Chase and the Cincinnati kid.
- Sorry. We don’t normally let Ohio teams make the playoffs in back-to-back years.
- I could win a shootout. I’m an actual cowboy.
- Shhhh, we’re a defensive team now.
- Wait, that’s the man who beat us.
We used to be the fun team!
- [Together:] Not our precious Chiefs!
- Time to Mixon it up and run.
- [Offscreen:] WHO DEY?
- Nobody.
- Wait, this is Cincinnati? I feel like the Bengals stole our—
- It’s a whole thing. Taysom, JUST DRIVE.
- Today’s Zac Snack: more chili!
- [Derek Carr:] WE'RE HERE TO RAID!
And I swear we're open to a tie.
- What do you think, Uno?
- I’ve eaten a lot of chili...
so it’s time to air it out.
- Are they posing?
- Man, they're cool!
- I’M CIRCLING THE WAGON!
- WILL UNO CHASE AND THE CINCINNATI KID COLLAPSE IN THE PLAYOFFS LIKE THE BENGALS OF OLD?
DID GRIDIRON HEIGHTS JUST CURSE  CINCINNATI LIKE THEY DID…
THE 2018 BEARS,
THE 2019 BILLS,
AND THE 2020 BEARS?
AND WILL ZAC TAYLOR MAKE ENOUGH FOOD FOR HIS HUNGRY LADS?!
FIND OUT NEXT WEEK ON GRIDIRON HEIGHTS!